कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत
कि आज हम सीखने वाले हैं जर्मन में
इंपोर्टेंट मतलब आज्ञाचक्र या आदेश देना
मतलब क्या कि जब हिंदी में बोलते हुए इधर
आ इधर जा यह सब क्या है अज्ञान है और यह
बात तो सिंपल है कि भी आज्ञा जो होती है
वह सामने वाले को दी जाती है राइड तो
जर्मन में भी वही होगा कि मैं जो सेकंड
पर्सन रूप है उनके लिए आज्ञा दी जाएगी तो
वह कौन-कौन से हैं देखते हैं चलो हम्म तू
मतलब तू हेयर मतलब तुम सब और जी मतलब आप
तो यह तीन फॉर्म में आप इंपरेटिव बना सकते
हैं तो हम इन रिटेल यह तीनों फॉर्म अभी
देखते हैं
को सबसे पहले जी जी मतलब आप हलवा पॉवर
बोलना है कि आप चाय पीजिए तो एक सिंपल
इट्स वेरी सिंपल नार्मल सेंटेंस क्या होगा
जी 3 घंटे अभी इंपरेटिव में किसी भी का
रूप को इंपरेटिव में हमेशा वर्क पहले आएगा
तो क्या उसको थोड़ा जोर देना चाहते हैं कि
इससे फर्क को पहले लेकर आओ कि रिंकल्स
बेटे 3 घंटे सिंपल है या फिर आपको बोलना
है धीरे से बोलिए आप तो क्या होगा
एक्सप्रेशन जिला एग्जाम प्रेमचंद जी
लांगटांग अगर इसको थोड़ा और सॉफ्ट करना है
तो अब बिटिया लगा सकते हो 3 घंटे विंटर तो
अपऑन हिस रिक्वेस्ट है कि आगे मतलब आप
ऑलमोस्ट आज्ञा से रिक्वेस्ट कोई आगे तो पर
तो इसीलिए तो यह रजि0 पर अगर असली आज्ञा
नहीं दी जाती है तो वह दूर ऊपर है तू इधर
इधर जो तू यार तू में दी जाती है तो वह हम
सीखते हैं
हंसकर बोले तुम सिंपल तो इसमें क्या करना
है ध्यान से सुनिए कोई भी वर्ग लोग उसका
दो फोन लगा लो उसका दो फ्रॉम बनाओ उसमें
से टेस्टी हटाओ अंदर से फॉर एग्जांपल की
ट्विंकल ट्विंकल का तूफान क्या बनेगा
ट्रेंस प्रिंस में टेस्टी हटा दिया क्या
रहेंगे ट्रिक तो * चाय पी प्रिंट के
अतिरिक्त ए सिमिलर कर बोलना है लर्न जर्मन
लर्न जर्मन तो लहसुन का क्या होगा लेंस
उसमें से हटाओ लेमन तो एक लेयर dont अभी
आप दोनों कि प्रियंका ड्रिंक लो या ग्लू
यह तो उस टाइम ही तत्वों ने ऐसे क्यों
नहीं पड़ा तो उसका भी इधर मैं आपको बताता
हूं यह हमने किया क्योंकि इससे हमको
इरेगुलर वर्ब्स में फायदा होता है फॉर
एग्जांपल विद ए को हेल्पलाइन हेल्पलाइन का
फील होता है वह लेफ्ट क्यों हुआ था
क्योंकि एल्बम का दूर किया है हिल मिष्टी
हटा
कि फिल्म हेल्प मी हिल्स नियर या फिर आपको
बोलना है बोल तो क्या होगा परेशान का
स्पर्श होगा इसकी हटाया वृष लग्न वृष लग्न
सिंपल है राइड अभी एक छोटी सी चीज क्योंकि
बहुत वक्त बाद में वह पूछते हैं कि मुझे
अपने क्लास में बहुत लोगों ने पूछा था कि
यह एग्जांपल देखो लायजन लिजम का होता है
दूर लिस्ट दूर लीव्स और उसका कॉर्ड ऑल है
तो क्या होता है यह चीज प्लीज अभी पौधों
कि हमने तो एसटी का एक है ही नहीं तो
थोड़ा वक्त लगता है रे पर ध्यान से देखो
जब अपने लेखन का दूर लिस्ट बनाया तो आपने
उसको एक स्ट्रेस दिया कि नहीं आपने लेने
को बोला कि मैं तुम्हें बहुत हम आपको 31
देंगे करेक्ट है तो जो वापिस लोगे तो यस
कैसे देगा वह रेट इसीलिए
कि लहसुन का लीव्स होता है कि हमने दो
करते हुए दिया टीम वापिस क्लियारिटी आगे
आपको अभी थोड़ा हार्ड लग रहा है तो लिव या
धर्म व सिंपल स्टेप्स विद ए यह डिफिकल्ट
फॉर ऑल द वर्क विचारों एडिटर एंड अपडेट्स
टाइम संजय ए सिंपल कंटेंट के लिए स्पॉट
फिक्सर सबको धूप हम समझ में आया अभी थर्ड
फोर्थ ईयर फ्रॉम मतलब बहुत सारे लोगों से
बात कर रहे हो जिनको रिस्पेक्ट नहीं देना
है तू भी - की सिचुएशन में को ज्यादा पता
नहीं कहां-कहां आती है ए सिचुएशन मेरे
दिमाग में है कि भाई आप टीचर और बच्चों को
पढ़ा रहे उधर सिंपली सिचुएशन नजर आई
अंडरस्टैंड तो बेसिकली अ आपको और बच्चों
को बोलना है बच्चों शांति से बोलो तो क्या
होगा परेशान का तुम सिंपल है यह रॉ बनाओ
डेट शीट अा
कि किंडर
एक स्पेशल का यह रुख किया होता है इस
प्रेस टिंडर स्प्रिट लांग करेक्ट इधर को
बच्चों दूध पी लूं कैलेंडर प्रिंट मिर्च
टिंडर ट्रिक मिर्च एकदम SIM प्लेयर कुछ भी
नहीं है अब यह चीज इंपोर्टेंट ध्यान में
रखनी है कि जब आप भी का रूप बना रहे थे जब
Quikr बना रहे थे तब जी यूज करोगी मतलब
केमिकल Zee TV पर बाकी के दो रूप में आपको
बोलने की जरूरत नहीं है डिपोजिट और नॉट
रियली आधुनिक को आदत है कि नहीं बुला रहे
हैं इसलिए प्रेम कंसीड ठेके पर प्रिंट या
फिर प्रिंट मिर्ची से
ए क्लियर है सिर्फ जब जी का रुख होगा तो
वह दिए लिखित
का कंसेप्ट क्लियर है रेट एकदम सिंपल है
कि वह शुरूआत में व बकाया और डिपेंडिंग
अपऑन जी है दूर है यह उसका रोक लगे वेरी
सिंपल कंसेप्ट के आगे इन और एक छोटी सी
चीज हम कंपलीट करते हैं कि वक्त ज्वाइन कर
तो वहीं जैसे आपको बताया कि टू बी व हमेशा
ही कैसे भी चलता है इस बिंदु विश्व यहां
भी अलग चलता है तो उस करो कैसे चलता है कि
सिंपल मैं आपको देता हूं अगर आपको बोलने
आप पोलाइट रही विनम्र रहिए तो कैसे होगा
देखो जाएंगी क्योंकि दयनीय प्लेस अगर बोला
तू फ्लाइट रहे हैं इस लहर रिक्वेस्ट पर
फिर भी बोल रहा है तू फ्लाइट है तो क्या
होगा आ जाए प्लीज दायां-क्लिक और बच्चों
को कंट्रोल है तो किन्नर साइड होगी अगली
आगे और भी थोड़े-थोड़े छोटे से एक ऑप्शन
है वह हमेशा होते
कि हर लैंग्वेज में भी होते रहेंगे हमारे
लिए मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट क्या है देखो जो
बेसिक रूल है वह समझ लो तीन बेसिक रूल्स
हमने देखें आधे इंपरेटिव के सबसे पहले जी
के लिए जी के लिए हमने क्या किया कि वह
बाहर मत हथेलिया जीव लगाया और वह वर्स्ट
पोजीशन के लिए प्रेगनेंसी टेली उसके बाद
हमने दूर रूप देखा दूल्हों के लिए क्या
करना है उसका दूर बनाओ इसकी हटा मोड सेट
प्रिंट थे यहां पर दूर नहीं बोलना है
प्रिंटहेड और उसके बाद हमने यह भी सीखा
अगर आपको तक कई यूज करना है तो उसमें भी
सिमिलर नहीं शेयर कर लो यार बोलने की
जरूरत नहीं है टिंडर प्रिंट मिर्च टिंडर
प्रिंट मिर्च एकदम सिंपल है बट कुछ भी
हार्ड नहीं है इसमें मुझे आशा है कि आप
सबको एक कैंसर समझ में आई होगी हम मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में धन्यवाद